مع انقطاع الطرق القوميه بين الولايات
والعاصمه الخرطوم بسبب الحرب تزدهر تجاره
الحدوديه لسد النقص في السلع الضروريه ففي
دارفور غربيه السودان تصل يوميا عشره
سيارات الى ولايه شرق دارفور قادمه من
دوله جنوب السودان تحمل الكثير من السلع
الاساسيه توزع على عدد من مدن الاقليم
الان طريق الجنوب مخفف لنا 99% من المواد
الغذائيه تسعه وتسعين في المئه يعني احنا
تسعه وتسعين في الميه الان معتمدين على
جنوب السودان
معتمدين على الاعتماد ذاتي وحلا لشحن
الوقود يدخل البنزين القادم لاوغندا كسلعه
مؤقته هنا اضافه الى ما يصل من دوله ليبيا
لكنها واجس الخوف تسيطر على سائق الشاحنات
بسبب انعدام الامن والتفلتات
تظلوا التجاره الحدوديه باقليم دارفور هي
حلا للعديد من السلع الاساسيه في فصل
الصيف هذا لكن يظل التحدي قائما في فصل
الخريف الذي اقترب الان صالح ابو علامه
لقناته العربيه والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات